Hello everyone, I'm Stefan from Freewings and today I'd like to tell you a bit about the topic of legislation and air law.
It's perhaps a bit of an intimidating topic, or a topic that during the learning phase for the SHV exam you may like to push off to the side.
Maybe also because it appears at the very back of the booklet.
My goal today is to take away a bit of your apprehension and also to show you a bit of the practical relevance of this whole legal part.
At first glance it doesn't seem quite as practically relevant and exciting as, say, a section like meteo or flight practice.
But it's still relatively important that you understand these things and know the background,
so that you're safely and always legally moving through our relatively constrained,
complex airspace.
Right, it's a learning subject, that's quite clear — there are many paragraphs you have to memorise a bit,
many things written in the booklet that you don't have to deeply understand,
where it's more about cramming and learning them.
I'm not going to dwell on those things in this presentation.
I'm mainly concerned with the things you understand in the background
and above all the things you understand in the background, and above all the things you understand in the background.
I'm mainly concerned with the structure of the glider chart and how these airspaces interact with each other
and how you find your way around in there.
Because in the end, as with many topics, it's really important that you know where to look things up.
You don't have to know everything by heart or have the entire Swiss airspace chart memorised inside out.
You just need to know: if I go into this flight area, I have to,
check there and there, look this up, so that you can launch safely and with a good feeling.
Good, then we'll get started right away with the next few slides.
First perhaps about the definition of hang gliders.
We with our paragliders fall under the category of hang gliders,
and here, very broadly and simply, the definition is: a hang glider is foot-launchable
and shortly or immediately after launch it serves
to perform soaring flights — gliding and soaring flights, as the saying goes.
And there are quite different aircraft in this category.
As you can see, the deltas are in here, rigid wings as you see in the middle,
which are somewhat closer to a sailplane or aircraft,
aerodynamically speaking, but are nevertheless still foot-launchable.
And then we come along with our paragliders, which are also found in this category.
Then we come to the legal foundations.
So the federal government determines or authorises the legal provisions of Swiss airspace.
Oversight over the whole airspace lies with the Swiss FOCA, the Federal Office of Civil Aviation,
and the FOCA in turn delegates the implementation of all hang-glider provisions
to the SHV, the Swiss Hang-Glider Association.
The SHV mainly handles training,
exams, cooperation with insurance providers
for third-party liability insurance for our sport.
It takes care of competitions, youth development,
various flying sites, wildlife protection, airspaces,
and that all of this harmonises a bit and gives us a nice scope
to pursue our hobby in Switzerland.
The legal provisions are contained in the VLK.
That's the Ordinance on Aircraft of Special Categories.
The VLK mainly covers how, where and who is allowed to fly such a paraglider.
You can easily google this — of course you don't have to memorise every paragraph.
It's just important that you know what the VLK is and roughly what's in there
or what it's about.
It's also not an insane number of pages — about three, four, maybe five pages
that you can read through without having to memorise everything.
Then here come some more basics.
A hang glider — meaning a paraglider, delta or rigid wing — is not entered in the aircraft register.
That's special in aviation, because everything else has a registration.
Or for example in road traffic too, every car has to be registered.
An identification, however, has to be attached to the wing.
These are numbers that each pilot personally receives from the SHV and which then have to be attached to the wing.
It's also important here, even if you have several wings, that this number is always exactly the same number on the wing.
Always your personally issued SHV number.
Airworthiness, however, does not have to be checked by any authority.
So it's not like with a car, where you have to put it through the MFK every two years.
In other countries it's like that for paragliders.
In Switzerland we're relatively free here.
Or in other words, a lot is left to personal responsibility or common sense.
Nothing is prescribed, but it's recommended that you have a wing checked every two years.
You'll hear more about this in the materials chapter.
And of course it depends a lot on how many flights you do.
If you do very, very many flights, a check at a shorter interval might also make sense.
Then about the reserve parachute and the helmet.
Astonishingly that's not prescribed by law, only anchored in law for exam flights,
that you have to wear a helmet and carry a reserve parachute.
At competitions and other paragliding events, however, it's often the case that the organiser mandates it.
Simply for safety reasons, which absolutely makes sense.
Then it's very important that we have hang-glider liability insurance.
We have a cooperation between the association and a large insurance company in Switzerland,
which then makes sure that with very many participants we can secure good insurance.
Because if you have an accident, you're normally covered through your accident insurance,
via your employer or your health insurance.
But if you cause damage to someone on the ground or to an object on the ground,
for example after landing some branches come down and fly into a car,
then your private liability insurance doesn't cover that.
And that's where it's really important that you've taken out such a hang-glider liability insurance.
Landing and launching on public roads and also ski slopes is forbidden.
It's very important to abide by this.
And what also makes things easier, no minimum number is specified for hang-glider flights.
So your brevet, once you have it, doesn't expire in that sense.
It naturally makes sense to stay active, to gain a lot of routine in this sport.
Or that if you've had a longer break, you also do a refresher course.
But legally no minimum number of flights is prescribed.
Then Swiss airspace is fairly densely packed.
We're very densely populated in this country and also have heavy air traffic.
But besides everything happening in the air, it's also very important
to follow certain rules on the ground.
And here I'd especially like to point to all the federal protected areas and cantonal wildlife refuge zones.
There are also private protected areas as well as many local agreements with game wardens and hunters.
You can find a large part of these on this page, on map.geo.admin.ch,
where you can also find the various wildlife refuge zones.
Where you can also find the various wildlife refuge zones.
Here you can for example filter out the hunting ban areas.
And if you click on them, you can see from when to when they're active.
This way we can spare wildlife and nature as much as possible and thereby protect them, so that we can protect our sport.
So that we don't run into too much trouble here.
This is a very important topic that is also addressed on the SHV homepage.
addressed under Flying Area and Wildlife Protection.
If you go in there, you can also download Hang Gliding and Wildlife,
the document as a PDF.
It's very interesting to see which species are threatened where
and what to watch out for and at what time of year.
I can warmly recommend taking a look in there.
But in this presentation we'll mainly limit ourselves to the airspace part.
So we go straight on with right-of-way.
In aviation it's always right-of-way to the right.
It's very similar to road traffic.
The pilot coming from the right has right-of-way.
Only there's one big difference to road traffic:
we can't simply stop or hit pause.
When we get close to each other, we have to act quickly,
although the paraglider is one of the
aircraft that flies very slowly,
we still have to live by the motto 'see and be seen',
really look ahead,
try to anticipate what the others in the air
might intend, where they might want to fly through,
and that you actually start to evade
before it even gets tight
or before you're even faced with the decision,
hey, who has right-of-way now?
So actually the goal is to react beforehand,
so that you don't gladly end up in a situation where it gets tight.
The distance is in fact also not defined.
It's simply described as a sufficient safety distance.
Here too, common sense.
Better to keep a bit more distance than too little.
Better to come up a bit short on a landing or evade somewhat
and land somewhere off to the side, when things somehow get tight.
On the topic of wingtip vortices and what it's like when you fly too close to each other,
you'll also hear about that in flight practice or aerodynamics.
Right.
Overtaking in free airspace is allowed.
On the slope it's forbidden.
We'll get to the slope right-of-way rules in the next slides.
In the thermal core, also a recurring situation
you experience in everyday flying,
where you fly into the thermal core
and then have to be aware of which direction you're turning.
And that's actually quite interesting.
It's not the lowest or the highest pilot who dictates which way it goes,
but the wing that's first in this core
sets the direction of turn.
So even if you fly in higher than someone else,
if the one down there turns left, you also have to turn left,
because it can happen that the one below you flies a bit better,
has a better wing,
that simply climbs nicer in the thermal and catches up with you.
And if you're then at the same altitude and turning in opposite directions,
then when you come towards each other
you have quite a high speed differential,
which could again become dangerous.
That's why it's always really important to turn in the same clockwise direction.
And interesting too — watch out
that you also turn with the birds in the same circle
or in the same clockwise direction.
That might sound funny, but the birds too,
in our latitudes,
because paragliding is very widespread,
have got used to us and in most cases peacefully turn with us.
But of course if we start turning against them,
they get scared too.
In the worst case we somehow drive them away from their home area,
which certainly wouldn't be good.
So there too, may sound funny,
but also make sure that you turn in the same clockwise direction as the birds.
And most of the time they fly much better than us anyway
and climb above us fairly quickly.
Then we come to the right-of-way rule on the slope.
Here again, when we fly head-on towards each other,
we evade to the right.
Not only when we approach each other at 90 degrees,
but also head-on always evade to the right.
On the slope it's then the case that one of these two wings
really has no options to the right
or can't really evade much.
Here too, it's of course nice
if the green wing now flies considerately
and starts evading early
and not just in the last few metres,
because of course the slope lift is often better closer to the slope.
Here too, yes, look out for each other,
evade early,
give a signal early — turn away from the slope,
so the other wing knows, hey, he has seen me
and is making room for me to fly past.
And often the lift very close to the slope
isn't necessarily better than a bit further out.
Right, that way we pass each other nicely.
Then there's also the definition of overtaking.
That's very theoretical now
and also very much focused on the legal part,
but it's described in the booklet.
And I've experienced it many times,
that flight students have asked me,
because they were a bit confused by this explanation or the depiction.
Here it's really mainly about
distinguishing what counts as overtaking
and what counts as simply crossing
or approaching from the right.
And here it's described with this angle of 70 degrees,
so 2 times 70 would be the 140 degrees toward the rear.
Anything approaching from behind counts as overtaking.
But if you're in front of this 70-degree line,
so the blue one now actually has right-of-way over the green one,
because he's coming from the right.
But the red one at the bottom left has no right-of-way,
because he's the one overtaking.
And the one overtaking never has right-of-way.
So the one being overtaken always has right-of-way.
Because he'd like to see what's happening behind him.
Right.
Again, in practice it happens rather less often,
because ideally well in advance
you try to get out of this situation.
And in any case never try to force right-of-way.
Then further right-of-way rules.
The aircraft at the top left is on fire,
or put differently, simply an aircraft
or an aerial vehicle
in an emergency,
has the most right-of-way,
because it can no longer manoeuvre well.
And these aircraft,
the helicopter or the motorised aircraft for example,
which are the most manoeuvrable,
they have no right-of-way.
So they have to evade.
And so the little ladder works its way down nicely.
The second would be balloons.
Logically they can't evade so well either.
After that, this is still interesting,
come paragliders and sailplanes.
We're in the same category here,
because a sailplane is travelling much faster
than a paraglider.
But in terms of right-of-way we're here
in the same category.
After that come zeppelins,
where we have right-of-way over zeppelins.
Then come towing motorised aircraft,
because they too are relatively manoeuvrable.
And at the end, aircraft and helicopters.
So, now we come to the main part
of this whole presentation.
And that's the glider chart.
Why is a glider chart needed at all?
Or what is a glider chart?
As the name suggests,
it's mainly for sailplanes and hang gliders.
On the glider chart are airspace classes,
hazards, flight restriction areas, obstacles,
soaring zones for us,
the new name is LSR for Gliders,
these are for us as paraglider pilots
and also for sailplane pilots here.
What exactly that includes,
we'll get to that shortly.
And also the military flight service hours.
And once again briefly on the why.
It's of course very, very important,
as said, in Switzerland the airspace is
relatively densely packed and relatively complex.
And that's why it's very important
that we stick to these airspaces
and only fly where we belong
and are well informed.
Because there have indeed been mistakes,
where paragliders have climbed so high in thermals
that they have entered an approach corridor
of an airport.
That's happened several times already.
That's just one example.
And it's of course in the first instance
simply extremely dangerous.
Mostly you can still react then,
in the ideal case.
But it leads to delays and extreme costs.
And the third point is simply,
it's incredibly bad for our image,
if of course this happens too often
near airports.
Then they simply say,
okay, in this case we forbid paragliding,
completely forbidden in this area.
And in Switzerland, where we have quite many airfields,
small and large,
that would already mean
that quite many flying areas would be at risk.
That's why it's very, very important
that you operate within the legal area here.
You can google the glider chart
and then it's the map.geo.admin.ch link
that you can open.
There you have the electronic, digital chart,
where you can also open a legend as a PDF,
where all the tags and symbols are described.
Personally I also find it good
if you have a physical chart in hand.
It just gives you a bit of an overview.
You can place things a bit better.
You just mustn't let yourself be too intimidated,
because at first glance it of course looks
extremely impressive or also complex.
But the good thing is,
that usually in the flying area
in which you fly,
and if you zoom in a bit,
it turns out it's not so bad,
like when you look at all of Switzerland
for the whole season.
Every March the new edition comes out,
which you can then buy.
I do it like this:
I don't buy the newest one every year.
I just have one,
that I then keep for two, three years,
just for a bit of an overview.
And before I go in the air,
I always go and check online anyway,
because then I have the most up-to-date version.
Then we come now to a few abbreviations
that you'll hear again and again
in the course of the presentation.
Also in connection with the glider chart.
The abbreviation GLDC is the glider chart,
the Glider Chart,
which we just briefly discussed
and will look at more closely afterwards.
The AIP is the Aeronautical Information Publication.
There we have generally applicable information
for all users of Swiss airspace.
Then we have the NOTAM.
That's a daily published source of information
for aviators,
where airspaces, restrictions
and also hazards and obstacles
on the ground are marked.
And the DABS,
the Daily Airspace Bulletin Switzerland,
that's actually,
alongside the glider chart,
the main tool
that I look at
before I go into the air.
Because the DABS also publishes daily
which airspaces are currently active
and where we mustn't fly in.
We'll also come back to this shortly later
with a practical example.
Then we have many abbreviations here,
which I would just recommend to you.
Take a photo or a screenshot.
These abbreviations come up again and again.
Very important, when it comes to altitude,
it's always good if you quickly check
whether it's above ground or above sea level.
That's namely very important,
so that no mistakes happen.
Then VFR, VFR is Visual Flight Rules,
so sight-flight rules.
And that's actually the area
in which we operate with the paraglider.
IFR, that is Instrument Flight Rules,
only aircraft go into this
that are also properly equipped.
For instrument flight.
And also only pilots
who have the necessary licence for it.
And we with the paraglider,
no matter how much GPS and how many instruments
we strap on in front of us,
cannot fly according to instrument flight rules
and also can't fly into the cloud.
We'll come to this too.
But really important to remember,
for us with the paraglider only the VFR applies.
Then later we'll also come to
the Flight Levels,
the flight surfaces and what all that includes exactly.
The three designations CTR, TMA and AWY
are mostly, or no,
always near airports.
So CTR always extends from the ground
up to a certain altitude.
The TMA are essentially the approach corridors
for takeoff and landing.
And the Airways are the longer airspaces,
the large main traffic flows,
which link the routes and connections
between airports.
We'll come back to this later.
Airspaces always have a name.
In Switzerland it mostly starts with LS.
The L stands for Lower Europe
and the S stands for Switzerland.
For example LSZR would be Altenrhein.
Then two more letters get added at the back,
which are then assigned here.
LSZH would be Zurich and then there are also
the Restricted Areas and so on.
We'll come back to this later.
Then there are worldwide
seven different airspace classes.
These were defined by the ICAO,
the International Civil Aviation Organisation,
at one point.
In Switzerland, however, only four apply.
That's the G and the E.
These are free.
That means you're allowed to fly into them.
The C and the D are only allowed with clearance
and radio contact to be flown into.
That means, if somewhere,
it might happen sometime,
when we're on a long cross-country flight,
that somewhere we just clip into an approach corridor.
Then we have the option
to radio in and under constant radio contact
we might then be able to
cross this approach corridor.
But that's of course not guaranteed.
That is only with clearance and constant radio contact.
Only in the E and the G can we always fly.